[Music]
good afternoon everybody my name is
Chris Latimer thanks for joining us here
I know that we're the only thing
standing between you and drinks at the
cocktail reception so we definitely
appreciate your attendance for our
session here today on securing the
enterprise with secure api's I just now
realized that rhymed I never actually
said it out loud before my name is Chris
Latimer I'm one of the field engineers
from Apogee now part of Google and I'll
let my my cohorts here introduce
themselves later on when they get to
their part of the presentation as well
really excited to be here and talk to
you guys today about this topic being
Appaji we absolutely love api's and so
what do we mean when we say api's when
we talk about API is an API security
today are we just talking about the
technical aspects of API what protocols
are we using system to system
integration and that type of thing
and the answer is no we really think
about API is more broadly we think about
them as a from a technical perspective
but we also think about them from a
business perspective and later on we'll
get to hear from Ticket Master and some
of the interesting things that they're
doing from an API perspective and how
they're securing their API s so if you
look at what all we're doing with API is
today it's hard to go even more than
five minutes without using an API of
some form if you check social media
you're using an API when you checked
into your flight check the flight status
that's another API call when you make a
purchase online that's also going to be
another API call so of course we need to
secure these API is very very important
data and functionality are running
through api's so we all we often want to
make sure that we're going to secure
those and our first reaction is to think
about something like this we're thinking
about well that's a lot of valuable data
that somebody could get access to that
maybe they shouldn't get access to and
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
lock this down as tightly as possible
put everything in the vault don't let
anybody get access to this stuff put in
place all the monitoring all the tools
that we can to to really lock this
important capabilities down and the
problem with that is that if all of your
API security starts to look like this
you're missing out on a lot of the value
that api's can bring
so the hard part of API security isn't
just locking everything down if we just
wanted to have a secure API we could
just not build any API is that's the
most secure API of all but putting
together a secure API that while still
being able to foster innovation inside
of your organization avoid putting in
place unnecessary delays red tape
bureaucracy doing all that while keeping
your API secure is a much much harder
problem to solve and so how do we do
that and in order to in order to think
about this problem I like to put it into
the context of imagine that you were
just creating a new account online you
see a new site you want to register for
an account and the way that we would
think about this process if the site
wants your email sure why not I give
this out all the time to any site it's
pretty usual that they want that they
want my address not a big deal to give
that information out it's usually pretty
easy to find you start to get to
something like a phone number well now
now I'm a little skeptical am I gonna
get robo calls are you gonna you know
text me is this for to factor auth is
there a good reason for it and if they
say something like oh what's your social
well now you're gonna slam the brakes on
you know almost nothing is going to get
access to that that information you
might think about it a little bit as
there a legitimate need for me to give
this information out if there might be
in certain cases you'll look and see is
this actually you know the site that it
claims to be or is this you know a
broken SSL cert and if you're
comfortable with the risk/reward you're
comfortable with with handing out that
information an API security requires a
similar approach we're gonna expose
different types of api's and they're
gonna have different types of security
requirements that we're going to want to
impose on those api's so let's look
through a few examples here let's
imagine that you're working for a
healthcare company maybe a hospital and
you want to create an API that's going
to expose Hospital locations and ours
public information there's nothing
sensitive about this so we can just open
it up and just let everybody go use this
thing like crazy well in a sense yes but
there are still
we need to be concerned about for
example this may be part of a mission
critical application for us this may be
what you know when you call up the
hospital and you ask where the nearest
location is somebody might be using the
same API when you go to the web site you
may be using the same API so if all of a
sudden you open this up and somebody
starts sending a flood of traffic your
way that can still cause pretty major
problems for you so we need to think
about that the traditional approach to
this is let's put in place heavyweight
governance well let's lock this down
let's not give anybody access unless we
go through a rigorous process to
understand how you're going to be using
this API how many calls are you going to
send to this but a better approach to
that is traffic management so we can put
in place things like quotas and spiked
arrests and so forth to limit our
exposure while still maintaining that
culture of fostering innovation another
thing that we'll usually do is try to
put into place a service registry let me
figure out exactly who's using which API
and make sure that we're tracking this
information very very closely a better
approach of that is to use something
like an API key where we can do this
automatically so rather than have a
registry that's probably going to get
out of date and out of sync and give us
unreliable information what we can do is
we can use an API key to automatically
make sure that each application that's
making an API call is authorized to do
so we also have to worry about
content-based attacks even though this
API may not expose sensitive information
on purpose if somebody starts sending in
like sequel injections or cross-site
scripting or those type of things we
have to still be cognizant of the
payload and make sure we're validating
that payload and a common way of
approaching this problem is with an API
gateway and because I came from Apogee
I'm gonna happen to mention we just have
a really good API gateway that solves a
lot of these problems that you have that
we're talking about today now I promise
this is not going to be a commercial for
Apogee but I did just want to mention
this so if you want to talk more about
Apogee in its capabilities we were happy
to do so so let's think about another
API let's think about one that all of a
sudden is opening up scheduling or
doctor availability so now we've got a
few more things that we have to think
about we have to start thinking about
we don't want anybody just registering
for access to this API and starting to
create appointments for doctors we want
to have a process in place that lets us
vet the partners who are going to be
using this API and the traditional
approach to this is to have a manual
process the same type of thing we're
going to have a form that somebody's
gonna fill out we're gonna take this
information we're going to decide
whether or not you get access to this
API a better approach is self-service so
rather than you answer a bunch of
questions about how your API works
instead of you looking through and
having conversations and meetings and
slowing things down and coordinating
schedules we can have a developer portal
that's going to give you the ability to
give your partner cell service aspects
self-service capabilities to register
for access to an API see the
documentation and start to use it right
away we are also going to need things
like authentication so we're going to
need identity we're gonna need to make
sure that the person that is registering
for is it a or that is scheduling an
appointment is the person that's the
patient in our system so we need some
way of identifying folks and the
traditional approach is going to be
direct user authentication if I have
partners who are going to be
authenticating my patients I don't
necessarily want them to have access to
that patients credentials instead a
better approach is to use delegated
identity and user authorization so we
would have things in here like open ID
connect social logins other logins where
our partners can redirect that user back
to our identity management solution so
that they can sign in and then we know
that it's actually them without the
partner ever actually seeing those
credentials now what if we start to get
into some really tricky areas what if
we're going to expose patient data we're
gonna give information about their
medical history what do we have to think
about then well now we have to think
about making sure we're not end up in
jail because we're breaking a bunch of
laws so there is a time in a place that
we need to have very very locked down
tight security in our AP is the point of
this presentation isn't to say that we
absolutely don't need to think about
tight API security we do and there are
times where that's absolutely
appropriate so we want to make sure that
the person who's looking at this data is
authorized is it your primary care
physician that should have access
this information or is it somebody for
marketing purposes that wants to sell
you a drug they probably shouldn't have
access to the information we want to be
able to have an audit trail we want to
be able to look back and see who has
looked at this over time one of the
hospitals that I've worked with before
have had issues where celebrities have
come in and people have wanted to kind
of see what's going on they're obviously
not something that you want to have
happen in a HIPAA compliant environment
and then there are all the basic things
- of course we need to still think about
TLS we need to use HTTPS we're going to
want to look at payload encryption in
certain cases to make sure that our data
is very very tightly locked down and so
from a general perspective these are
some of the things that we need to think
about from an API security as weird as
we're designing our API security and
with that I'm gonna hand it over to my
colleague Greg Braille who is gonna talk
about a few specific use cases and case
studies that we that we've seen in the
wild thanks Chris so I'm gonna talk now
a little bit Chris has talked about the
context why do we want to select
different types of API security when is
it true is it important to have
everything locked down to the max versus
making things flexible developers but
what I really want to also talk about is
get into a little more detail about API
security and ways to secure API sand the
reason why I think it's important to
talk about this if you're a web
developer or have even come close to web
development and you work for any sort of
moderately large company you've probably
had to go through some sort of mandatory
training where they taught me about all
the things that can go wrong with web
app development and you learned about
CSS attacks and sequel injection and all
kinds of things like that um we don't
have that for api's and api's are a
little different than web apps there are
some things that can happen to web apps
that don't happen to api's there are
some things that happen to API is that
you don't think about as much when
you're building a web app so I wanted to
make sure we talked a little bit about
API security and one of the ways I like
to do it is by talking a little bit
about some of the things that can go
badly when you don't think about all the
aspects of API security that are
important so for instance if you
remember nothing else everything that
has a URL or if I'm really fancy I'll
say you
I has an API so Chris said you know
earlier you know one way to seek you
make make an API secure is not to have
one that's true but if you built a
mobile app and the mobile app talks to
some service on the Internet you have an
API you might not have advertised it
develop developers you might not have a
swagger spec for it you might not have a
github repo with sample code but you
have an API and a reasonably smart
person can at home
jiggy up their their Wi-Fi router to see
what's going on between your app and
your API and figure out what's happening
and a bunch of smart people have done
this to embarrassing effect for instance
the highly critical Enterprise API run
by kylie jenner was broken to by a 19
year old who looked at it and discovered
that his kylie jenner mobile app or
actually her website had no API security
and he could get some interesting
information similarly here's a great
article I found on programmable web that
came out about a year ago titled how to
use undocumented api's to hack your
Tesla that's something that you know if
you own a Tesla it's kind of cool hey I
can hack my Tesla but the truth is that
you know these are all cases of when
people actually were able to look in and
see what was happening between the
client and the server and figure out the
API so when we ignore the fundamentals
of API security because we don't have an
API you have to really ask yourself you
know well do we have an API you know
maybe if you know if everything is
inside one room or one land okay we
don't have an API but otherwise we do
and as enterprise networks get larger as
companies get larger as things like as
companies have global networks
everything is effectively an open
network nowadays so you have to assume
that when you design your apps so why
our API is important and why is API
security important well a really great
example I can talk about here is the
world of banking is especially in the
u.s. a lot of people use services like
mint or Yali which will do aggregation
of their bank account information is
Quicken a lot it has a similar feature
and if you use any of those services the
first thing you do they said they do was
say great give me your bank account
username and password and one of I
should have used one of Chris's
you know disturbed person at images for
that one because once someone says give
me your bank account username and
password it means what they're gonna do
is they're gonna store your bank account
password yeah they're going to encrypt
it but they've got a decrypt it in order
to use it and then they're gonna screen
scrape your bank's website they're gonna
make HTTP requests as if they were a
red-brown web browser they're gonna
parse the HTML and they're gonna figure
out what your bank is telling them so
basically some of the bank's have
started to realize that this is not
great for security because when their
end-users are giving their passwords to
these third parties you don't know what
the third parties are doing with them
you don't know if the third parties are
storing that data in a safe way even if
they're storing that data in the safest
way possible they still have access to
their end-users unencrypted passwords
and those passwords give you access to
do everything you can do from your
bank's website including transferring
large sums of money making big stock
trades whatever you can do if we had
took an API approach on the other hand
where banks were to offer api's that use
the security mechanism such as ooofff
that would mean that as an end user you
would not give these third parties your
password you would instead go through an
authentication process with the bank
that gives the third party a token and
that token can now be set up by the bank
to only offer access to these specific
specific things that the bank wants them
to have access to so for instance
JPMorgan Chase realized this and wrote
something in their annual report and
they got into a little bit of trouble
with the New York Times that said you
know Jamie Dimon wants to protect you
from innovation and he has a point and
they have a point too but the idea here
is by offering open api's with
well-known API security techniques such
as oweth we can have a much much better
handle on security security is not about
eliminating all risk security is about
managing risk and by giving third
parties a way to have access to
important information like financial
information in a controlled way where
you're only allowed to do what the bank
allows you to do we're in a much better
position than we are today where you
give someone your password and they can
do anything so I'm now going to talk
about five or six specific API security
things and kind of use some examples
right so one big AP
security mistake we can make is to not
use TLS or SSL as it used to be called
and now the protocol we're supposed to
use today is actually called TLS so for
instance the security researcher did a
study last year and he discovered that
around the world especially in South
Asia um at the time something like 30%
used non encrypted links two years ago
that was 90% now maybe that's not your
password but we're to the point now on
the internet where everything that is
even slightly important and in fact even
everything that isn't should be
encrypted with TLS that's why Google
comm when you do a Google search is
encrypted with TLS the cost is just not
there
but it's more than just hey remember to
use TLS don't put an unencrypted API in
the Internet it's how you use TLS so for
instance in some frameworks for the
client it's very easy to turn off TLS
verification because you're doing
development and it's kind of a pain to
get the right certificate and you know
the name on the DNS record doesn't match
the certificate and were in a hurry so
we'll just check that box in nodejs or
PHP or Java or whatever that says don't
verify the TLS certificate that opens it
up for your client app to be able to
have its supposedly secure web traffic
be intercepted by anyone in Starbucks
who has control over the Wi-Fi or over
the DNS router TLS verification is
tremendously important not only that
TLS has a bazillion options what version
are you using 1.0 1.1 1.2 what cipher
suite are you using are you using a
lipstick curve what encryption algorithm
are you using and these things change
all the time so as anybody who's
offering an API or any web app and is
using TLS you have to remember to keep
up with what's happening in the security
world follow the best practices from
your security people than your company
and elsewhere and make sure that you're
continually evaluating how you're using
this technology and keeping up with the
latest attacks for instance I still see
developers sometimes occasionally want
to write code and they want to hash
something and they use md5 md5 has been
a no-no on the security world for years
you infected Google that's not even in
the codebase that they took it out right
but people still remember this from if
few years ago so this is why it's very
important anytime encryption is used to
really think about this so now we move
on to some of the other basics of api's
Chris talked about api's that require an
end-user to be authenticated there are
all kinds of things that can go wrong
with this so for instance the Nissan
Leaf a little while ago came with a
mobile app and the mobile app let you do
things to your car like turn on and off
the climate control or start your car
remotely and it's to make it easy for
people to use the app the authentication
mechanism for the app required you to
put in the cars VIN number which is a
unique ID that's on every car it's
actually on the dashboard of your car so
it's not a secret and it is it is
structured in such a way that every type
of car most of the digits are the same
and only the last five digits vary so
you could imagine that if you knew that
hey I can turn on the climate control on
one Nissan Leaf using a VIN number what
if I were to cycle through ten or
fifteen thousand VIN numbers and see if
I could do that to other Nissan Leafs in
the world and a security researcher
named Troy hunt figured out that the
answer was yes though I'm not saying
this to make a Nissan look bad because
they fix this I'm saying this to give
you an example of what happens when you
don't think through API authentication
there are a lot of best practices out
there for basic things like signing
users in checking passwords resetting
passwords it's actually pretty hard to
get right
companies like Google do a good job of
it smaller companies that are
specialized in the security world do a
good job of it
large companies that don't don't always
do a great job of it I've seen some
horrible password reset practices from
various websites I use in my life these
kinds of things can show up as massive
API security vulnerabilities if you're
not careful but it's not just about
authenticating the end user in the world
of API is one thing we do that we did
not do in the world of web apps is we
also authenticate the application if you
were to ask me what does API management
do because I am an API management guy
that's what we do at Apogee API
management is about managing the
relationship between the developers who
build applications and the api's that
they use and a big part of that is
managing those
any credentials ooofff which is the de
facto standard for API security now and
in fact from a lot of security now has
built into it the concept of application
credentials in order to build an
application that gets an OAuth token say
to use a Google cloud API you not only
have to supply some user credentials but
you've got to supply application
credentials which the application
developer gets as part of the
development process now the application
credentials are not 100% proof against
attacks right I mean any anybody who has
access to the application can use those
application credentials but what they do
is they give the security team a lot of
extra layers of defense and that's what
security is really about so for instance
we have had cases of appaji edge
customers who had we had one who
accidentally pushed their version of an
app to the App Store that had a bug in
it and it was actually hitting an
authentication API in an infinite loop
hundreds of times a second and it was
soon overwhelming their whole technology
stack now if they had a different set of
application credentials for every
version and platform of that app they
actually would have been able to cut
that off app off instantly in their API
management tier or redirect traffic from
that app to some sort of other server
which is able to mediate it and as a
matter of fact they didn't quite did
that but they did have the application
authenticated so they were able to take
some of those steps but that's an
example of why it's important to not
only authenticate the end user but the
application this also gives you an
opportunity to do some things like
analytics and we'll talk a little bit
later about bot detection but knowing
which application is making an API call
is one of the pieces of information you
can use in that world now I mentioned
ooofff ooofff has been around for a
couple years it's become the de facto
standard for API security and basically
one reason why it works is because what
it allows you to do is it allows a
client who makes an API call to exchange
some credentials for a token and that
token gives you access to the API and
with OAuth it's possible for the API
provider using software like Apogee or
many other bits of software to control
what a token is allowed to do
furthermore unlike a password a token
uniquely identifies a single application
on a single device it's not just a
generic bit of security information and
OAuth tokens can be refreshed but ooofff
is a fairly complex family of specs
there i ET f standards there are a lot
of smart people including some of our
security folks at Google working on it
but there are lots of ways to use OAuth
so for instance there one way to use
OAuth is to make an API call RIA send in
your password and get back a token
another way to do it is to have the
user's device open up a web browser
window where they can get a token by
being redirected to a website and that
website can do additional things like
check cookies ask for a second factor do
all kinds of things like that now it
turns out that the OAuth folks have
actually been working on a spec that
describes hey these are the best
practices for how to use OAuth in a
native app we recommend using this web
browser redirect method and here's how
to do it safely on different mobile
platforms furthermore there have been a
couple of things that have been found as
vulnerabilities in the OAuth specs that
have been fixed in some of the newer
IETF specs so it's really important if
you're going to use OAuth to pay
attention to some of the requirements
that you see in the community in some of
the discussion that goes on especially
in the IETF
because there are a lot of smart people
who have wrote in a lot of really good
stuff about how to use OAuth correctly I
should also mention authorization and in
this form of authorization I mean once
you've authenticated a user and you know
who they are what are they allowed to
use it's easy to make some dumb mistakes
this one security researcher discovered
that his bank actually I don't think it
was a very big bank but they actually
were not verifying the account numbers
on the back end so he figured out the
API that his mobile app was using and he
was able to transfer money from any
accounts to any other account in the
bank
now that's a huge mistake right that's
like you know people are getting fired
mistake but you know these kinds of
things can happen developers don't
always think of these things one of the
things I like about api's is that an API
is a contract and it's exactly clear
what is supposed to be sent between the
clients
and the server so unlike a web app where
you're downloading JavaScript and
executing who knows what a provider of
an API can specify exactly what sent
exactly what's received what are the
valid responses are that means you can
write test plans and regression tests
and penetration tests and you can verify
that what you think your API is is what
you're actually implemented I think
that's actually an advantage of api's
and it's an advantage of API security
and by having that kind of spec and by
thoroughly testing that spec you should
be able to vent these kinds of dumb
authorization mistakes that they you
know they're easy to laugh at now but
you know there but for the grace of God
though all of us write another one this
is really important is rate limiting so
the best example of API rate limiting I
could find came from a researcher that
did some work a couple of years ago on
snapchat when they were a much smaller
and less mature company he discovered
that given a phone number it was
actually possible to get information
about someone's snapchat profile now
that doesn't sound like a big problem
but it turned out that there was no rate
limit on this API and he was able to
send him huge batches of phone numbers
now if you could imagine say Beverly
Hills California
um I guess people use cell phones now
but even then it doesn't have that many
phone numbers in it it wouldn't take
very long to get a lot of interesting
information that way so this was Annie
this was to me the best example of in
the real world
an API that should have had some sort of
rate limit to help with security and I
mentioned this because pretty much any
API that could be subject to brute-force
attack is something that will be subject
to a brute force attack and it may be
subject to a brute force attack by
someone who's just hammering it for fun
but it could be somebody with legitimate
credentials lots of people can sign up
for these services so things like
product IDs um user names if you can
like put in someone's phone number and
get information another great example is
that ooofff password grant type where
you send in your password anon API call
and you get back to security token well
if there's no rate limit on that now you
have a distributed password cracking API
that people can now use
crack your password database so it's
great to monitor and this stuff is
important but by having basic rate
limits on api's like no one should call
this API more than 500 times a second or
a given application is is limited to a
certain number of API calls per day or
hour or month or even possibly
introducing artificial delays to some
api's that may be called very frequently
those make a very very big difference in
the kind of security posture you have
and prevent these kinds of attacks and
also we're gonna finally mention the
most you know probably the the biggest
security
you know list of things that developers
need to know about comes from Olaf's
butts called the top 10 I couldn't find
anything since 2000-2001 the internet
interestingly enough they don't all
apply to native apps that use api's if
you're building api some of the
JavaScript things and cross-site
scripting things don't really apply to
you but the rest of it does injection
attacks miss configuration of security
bad authorization decisions a lot of the
things that I've talked about are in
here but there are some things I didn't
talk about as well for instance the
number one attack is an injection attack
so classic sequel injection stuff like
you know can I put you know semicolon
you know delete star from customers in
my user name it applies to API is just
as much as it applies to web apps yes
there are things you can do with regular
expressions and stuff to protect from
this but it's really really important
that as application developers we remain
just as cognizant of this in the world
of api's as we do in the world of web
apps so to sum up this partner that I'm
gonna talk for two or three more minutes
and turn it over to Ismail I think
everyone needs to know some basic things
about API security and this is not
necessarily the same things you need to
know for web app security and a big part
of it in my opinion is understanding the
importance of things like rate limiting
traffic management content attacks and
basically the idea that anything that
can be called with a URI someone is
going to figure out what your app is
doing and
to break it and as app developers we
have to be very cognizant of that at the
same time by designing api's that follow
the right security principles by making
smart choices about how much security we
need on an API and by making sure that
our API definitions are clear and well
understood
we've now designed something that we can
test that has a much smaller surface
area than a web app and I would argue if
you follow all the rules and you do
everything right if possible to make
things with api's that have fewer
security risks than what we see today
with web apps now I'm gonna talk for
just a short time about Apogee edge this
is the product that has been acquired by
Google as part of Google cloud and
basically what we do in Apogee is we
provide a product that lets us insert
ourselves into the world of api's so
many companies when they're looking to
offer an API they're asking themselves
how do i implement a lot of these things
how do i implement OAuth and connected
to my users to my existing user
authentication system my existing single
sign-on system how do i implement a rate
limit how do I do checks basic threat
protection checks like malformed JSON
and XML these are the kinds of things
that we've always been built into the
apogee edge product and the idea of edge
is that as an API provider you can put
the API management product and there are
a lot of products in this category in
front of your API and it can handle a
lot of these aspects so that your
back-end
the stuff your developers are building
you don't have to build this into every
service the larger the company you are
the more it makes sense to have one
place where you apply many of these
security policies as opposed to building
them into every single application many
large companies Google has an API
management for its own API s all the big
companies that have api's have API
management as part of their software
stack at the edge of the network
somewhere between the load balancers and
firewalls and the stuff that actually
runs the API is what Apogee edge is it's
a product that allows you to configure
it to be that API management layer for
the API and configure it however you
need it to work
now I'm gonna talk for two minutes here
about Apogee cents and it's the last
thing I'm gonna talk about which is a
thing that we've used to extend Apogee
and this is gonna segue nicely to what
its male is gonna talk about is we're
gonna talk a little bit about bots so
there are all kinds of bad things that
can happen to api's people who are not
legitimate users may try to hammer your
API to crack it to brute force it just
to mess with you but what can also
happen which is a little bit more subtle
and harder to deal with is when
legitimate users who have got legitimate
application and end-user credentials use
your API is in an illegitimate way this
happens a ton for instance in the travel
industry where you know gee every Hotel
has the same prices well it's because
somebody somewhere is screen scraping or
bahding the api's of all the other hotel
websites and trying to book a room in
every single price category to try and
find out what the prices are and what
the availability is right there's a lot
of bots that happen in retail this mail
comes from Ticketmaster some of you may
have used Ticketmaster they have some
experience with bots as much as they're
able to tell us so Apogee cents is a
product that uses the fact that we
collect a lot of data in the apogee
platform about the api's that we handle
and basically we can use that
information it's information about IP
addresses and things to figure out and
to score incoming API calls on whether
or not we think they might be a bot
some of this is heuristic like for
instance American retail companies don't
have a lot of customers in Eastern
Europe or some of it is heuristic like
iPads tend not to be located in Amazon
data centers some of it is machine
learning and some of it is you know
standard Big Data stuff
you know it was 100 off token used to
make more API calls than a human user
could have made using an app was one
OAuth token used to scan through API is
like to scan through all the phone
numbers in Beverly Hills from 0 0 0 0 to
999 these are the sorts of things that
you can see and by looking for patterns
like this we're able to then score
incoming API calls as you know
definitely a bot like we know this IP
address is a bot because everybody is
getting bot traffic
- probably not a bot - something in
between and then take action sometimes
take action is block the API call but
that lets the bot people know that
you're blocking them so sometimes the
better action is to let the backend know
so it can provide a different results a
different price a different availability
even slow down the API traffic so that's
kind of what what we're looking at doing
so with that that's really all that I
have to say about Apogee I'm now gonna
turn it on to Ishmael who is an SVP at
Ticketmaster and is gonna talk to us
about his experiences with AP is an API
security thank you guys whoa it's loud
hi everyone thank you Apogee and Google
for having me here this is really
exciting to be here to talk to you guys
about our experience with API is from a
business perspective I'm going to talk a
little bit about the tech involved as
well so Ticketmaster we're all about
delighting global fans in the
distributed world right a little bit
about myself before I jump into that
I've been I've been in this battlefield
of tech and and product for a while now
been I started as a software engineer in
in back-end engineer and front-end
engineer been doing api's for the last
seven years or eight years joined touka
Master 18 months ago and to open up the
platform and open up their api's and six
months ago i started running the entire
product organization consumer product
organization so very very exciting so
show of hands who's been on Ticketmaster
in the last six months
try the buy tickets I can't see not a
lot actually it's just surprising so
keep your hands up keep it up if you
were not able to buy tickets when you
visit the Ticketmaster well I don't need
I don't need this I don't need to talk I
don't need to talk it's all good it's
happening well we have one person ok I'm
here for you man I'm here for you so we
have problems not every fan that comes
to Ticketmaster dot-com could buy
tickets so that's why when we started
with really got me excited about the
opportunity to take
master is a leadership there Jody Mulkey
the CTO and and the entire team is that
we're really reinventing Ticketmaster
we're changing the way we're selling
tickets and that's by having a fan first
thinking from our infrastructure and and
and completely changing and upgrading
our infrastructure we have an incredible
partnership with AWS and Amazon we're
removing our private cloud into AWS and
it's a process that we're working on
right now into opening our api's and
that's a partnership that we have with
Apogee that's that's been fantastic so
infrastructure opening up opening up the
api's and then our products had to be
built with fans in mind first which is
not traditionally the way it's been done
in the past and what that means is that
really looking at all our fans our
different personas and understanding why
we're building the products that we're
building right and our promise to our
fans is that we are unlocking moments of
joy for global fans through
unforgettable product experiences so if
you think about that and thinking about
the fan and fan first you'll see that
and I don't know if you guys follow
Ticketmaster we have been changing the
way we offer value to fans so for
example this happened today
it's a pre-sale for Ed Sheeran's coming
to the North America this is gonna be
one of the biggest tours this year his
new album dropped a week ago and it's
killing it right but this way is for us
to say hey fans pre-register and we will
text you a link you know before the
pre-sale where you can buy a cheering
tickets who did it with 1975 John Mayer
Depeche Mode you name it because what we
find what we find is that when fans come
to Ticketmaster for the passion mode for
example who they haven't toured in seven
years and if you can't get tickets
you're gonna freak out because I will
freak out too because I've been wanting
to go and I signed up and I got yes we
have a fan in the house I love it but
it's real right no one's gonna drop four
thousand dollars to go see Beyonce at
the Rose Bowl if they're thinking
logically right so it's it's an
emotional business that we're in we
want to make sure that fans are not
disappointed are not turned down and and
are actually getting the tickets that
they want we see 72 million unique
visitors a month now all of them are
fans right so we have a real real need
here and the real problem to solve with
with some of the challenges we run into
right so tickets are the only commodity
I can think of is that that go up in
price or up in value once you buy them
right I don't know if you guys bought
tickets to Hamilton recently right so
yeah I have not seen it I can't afford
it
but we deal with a lot a lot of issues
and a lot of problems box are one of
them right limit violations people are
trying to circumvent the limits we put
on an event so it has a fan you cannot
buy for certain events you cannot buy
more than eight tickets for some events
you cannot buy more than four tickets
just to make it fair and and and give
access to a lot of other fans that want
to go see the the the act and some
people and some bots and some bad actors
trying to circumvent that by they want
to get I don't know 100 tickets or you
know I'm talking about concerts now in
theatres not sporting events per se so
there's so there's that level of
complication and challenge that we have
and then the biggest challenge we have
is reserved and do not buy right so
during an on sale when people you know
bad actors come and and select a pair of
tickets or a bunch of tickets and they
don't actually end up buying them what
happens is that when they actually
select them that those tickets are put
into a hold and no other fans can get to
them which is bad we have ways of going
around that obviously we can we have
we've been doing this for a while now so
we we have our our own algorithms and
our own systems that can kind of
determine or try to glean whether this
traffic is coming from a good actor a
real fan a bad fan a robot and not a
robot and all of that good stuff but you
know that's just Ticketmaster calm take
your master out so that's just our
closed system but in order for us to
deliver on our promise to our fans our
global fans
we determined that we have to open up
the platform we have to make our api's
available to other developers to other
partners clients where they can build
applications that can build experiences
for their own fans so everyone get gets
access to those tickets so what when I
started 18 months ago what we did was we
consolidated all of these different
platforms that we have into one
simplified very easy to use platform
partnered with Apogee to expose those
api's and then we started using those
api's across the board in all different
channels starting with our own apps and
their own properties but also like in
for pre-sales on fan clubs for example
last-minute channels like you name it
right so we have different different
outlets for those api's but the reason
we wanted to go this route obviously to
open up the platform but also for any
measurement of security that we apply to
one channel now we apply it to the api's
and that's it we don't have to think
about it anymore right because when you
apply to the API is doesn't matter who's
using the API that the same level of
security is gonna be is gonna be applied
in in our world what Greg said that
security is not eliminating risk its
mitigating risk and for us it's all
about mitigating risk it's all about
mitigating risk you'll never know in
real time who's a true fan and who's a
bot so if you're like me who you know if
you go to a show once a once a week and
I pay out of pocket by the way I don't
get free tickets if you know how to get
free tickets let me know you my behavior
and my pattern of activity can look like
a bot to our system because that you
know I'm coming from you know my home
Wi-Fi trying to buy tickets to John
Mayer to 1975 so this and that and it's
like oh my god this guy or that entity
is buying a lot of a lot of tickets so
maybe it's you know suspect right we're
trying to make it smarter and better but
you know true fans and superfans can
come across as as bots and that's that's
a problem that we're trying to solve but
we opened up the platform we have a we
have a portal right developer
ticketmaster.com we created an ecosystem
where you can go to
to the portal and understand what API is
we have who's using them and how you can
get access to them we really followed
the all the best practices and
everything that you know
Appaji kind of advocates and puts out
there and from my previous experience as
well like all the best practices that I
learned you know the hard way sometimes
that we should be doing in order for you
for us to have a successful API program
so we done all of this stuff and we
integrated with some incredible partners
to get access and to reach other fans
that might not necessarily come to
ticketmaster.com
and as a result of that you know opening
up the platform and and and really
thinking broadly we've seen just last
year that 10% of all tickets sold by us
came off of platform came through
partners came through our API eyes
outside of our products fascinating
right but guess what
the challenges still remain the
challenges that we've seen in our own
expand our own products still remained
true in in the open platform world it
just got amplified actually almost all
the errors do we see in the apogee
portal for you know coming through our
API czar of these two kinds of errors
right too many requests rate-limiting
right so people trying to make too many
API requests trying to get access to
those tickets reserve them right and
because we have rate limiting it's it's
it's preventing our system from going
down and overwhelming our system but
also like really controlling the API
access for that particular user or
application but also like look at the
unauthorized calls a lot of people
trying to make calls without being
authorized with without the right o auth
token it's a real problem right and
because building an API a lot of people
think oh you know like it's a simple
interface and I have the SDK and
documentation it's pretty simple right
it actually takes a lot of effort and
planning especially when it comes to
security Identity Management who has
access to what
messaging all of that said there's a fix
of village right for the API to actually
be useful and and to be simple so that
that's that's the challenge we run into
so when we focus on the fan and opening
up everything and trying to you know
trying to think how do we make that
access of this API that we just put out
there favorable to fans through and for
developers to build applications that
actually let fans through so the way we
did it was really follow the basic best
practices I cannot emphasize that a lot
of times you know the biggest problems
happen because you know you don't follow
the the guidelines and the best
practices like authorization
authentication OAuth rate limiting using
you know Bob blocking that Appaji
provide if you're if you don't do this
for for for a living like we do SSL just
the basic stuff and if you do the basic
stuff you're actually like 50% they're
like Greg and Chris we're talking about
in our case we really had to think about
okay the reserved API call that's where
that's where actually people put real
tickets real value on hold right so we
need to rethink how that API call
actually works so the way we did it was
we were introducing friction we're
trying to introduce friction it's like
okay you cannot do that anonymously we
you're authenticated your application we
have the OAuth token great but now when
you want to know who's the actual user
making that call right because then I'll
have extra information about that user
that will help me determine should is
that really a legitimate fan or is that
a bot that's trying to that hack the app
and now using it and you know in a
really in a bad way right so introducing
friction by forcing registration or sign
signing in using whatever you want to
sign in for like we used to Kumasi
Ticketmaster accounts for that and using
the fan score which is our kind of
algorithm to to determine whether you're
a good actor about actor basically a fan
or
or and the last thing obviously which is
really really important is and we've
done we just did that with Apogee is
Identity Management entitlements right
so when somebody is making an API call
with their OAuth token right so if that
checks out that means you know after G
says okay this all off token is good now
taking their API key and their identity
and say you know pinging our system
saying what what role does this play or
have in our system are they a supervisor
are they a fan you know with a bunch of
tickets so they can transfer and all of
that stuff and once you get that back
you add a bunch of headers to the call
and then when we get it in our in the
backend we understand like if this
action is permitted by this user or not
so if you want to transfer some tickets
now everybody just because you're a fan
doesn't mean anything like you have to
be a fan and also have the the rights to
transfer those tickets or to sell those
tickets or to cancel an order so these
are the three learnings that we found
just opening up an API ecosystem and a
platform actually works really well is
it perfect it's not it's never going to
be perfect than we're always learning
every single day but the fact that we
sold 10% of our tickets off of platform
using our api's that we opened up just
18 months ago is a huge testament to the
the power of API is to the business but
also you know the fact that you have to
stay vigilant in order for you to to
really expand I mean we haven't really
touched we haven't scratched the surface
with api's just yet and with that I
thank you for being here and we're
hiring we want people to help us with
with this transformation that we're on
and I guess I'll open it up to questions
right
[Music]